[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia de kobe 19 en nuestro
continente a continuación les presento
algunos de los temas que vamos a tratar
en el programa
hablaremos de esta cifra los más de 5
millones de fallecidos que deja hasta
ahora la pandemia de kobe 19 en el mundo
una cifra que es lamentable y nos
recuerda lo importante que es seguir
cuidándose y garantizar el acceso a las
vacunas para todos los países y todas
las regiones del mundo los casos
comienzan también a aumentar en
diferentes regiones del planeta eso nos
recuerda que la pandemia no ha terminado
y que debemos seguir combatiéndola
también hablaremos de argentina y de
uruguay porque ambos países abrieron las
fronteras para el ingreso de los
extranjeros ante la leve mejoría de la
situación sanitaria también la alta
vacunación pero sobre todo con el ánimo
de reactivar la industria turística para
que dé un impulso a las economías de
cada uno de estos países los gobiernos
han tomado esta decisión vamos a ver
cómo está avanzando esta medida en unos
minutos con nuestros corresponsables y
en nuestra consulta con el doctor pérez
nuestro asesor científico no sólo 25
millones de fallecidos será uno de
nuestros temas sino que también
hablaremos de la controvertida
vacunación de menores la combinación de
vacunas para segunda dosis aclaro para
una segunda dosis y también las píldoras
contra el kobe 19 temas que tal vez ya
hemos tratado en otros programas pero
como cada semana hay novedades
relacionadas con este tema entonces las
vamos retomando y se las traemos acá al
programa para estar siempre actualizando
los en cuanto a estos avances por parte
de la comunidad médica
vamos a comenzar el programa y lo
hacemos con las cifras lo hacemos viendo
cómo está el panorama de la pandemia de
kobe 19 en el planeta en esta
oportunidad vamos a ver si las cifras
globales al día de hoy ha habido más de
248 millones de casos de kobe 19
confirmados los fallecidos pues ya
superan los 5 millones como ya les
estaba diciendo ya vamos a superar la
barrera o ya superamos la barrera de los
5 millones estamos aumentando
rápidamente en diferentes partes del
planeta al cierre de esta semana también
unas siete mil
186 millones de dosis de vacunas han
sido administradas en todo el mundo
y pues lo decíamos en el sumario del
inicio de este programa el mundo superó
ya los 5 millones de fallecidos por
cuenta del cob y 19 estados
unidos-brasil también india siguen
encabezando las cifras más altas de
víctimas mortales pese a que todavía
están también allí aumentando la
vacunación y la inoculación entre sus
ciudadanos así es como están las cosas a
nivel global
el nuevo coronavirus ya ha causado más
de 5 millones de muertes desde que la
oms decretó el estado de pandemia global
en marzo de 2020 entre los cerca de 247
millones de casos confirmados a nivel
global un año y medio después de las
primeras restricciones sanitarias este
primero de noviembre países como israel
uruguay o tailandia reabrieron sus
fronteras internacionales
bailan fortín mans el coronavirus me
mantuvo alejado de tailandia durante 18
meses y de mi mujer tailandesa durante
un año así que hoy es el primer día que
puedo regresar y espero poder ser feliz
en otras latitudes del planeta un método
para validar la reapertura ha sido la
imposición del pase sanitario pero en la
capital de marruecos rabat este
documento fue objeto de protestas
el pase sanitario es una violación de la
constitución y de las leyes
internacionales estamos aquí porque al
principio nos dijeron que era opcional
pero luego descubrimos que es
obligatorio somos los primeros a los que
nos importa nuestra salud nos preocupa
más que a ellos
desiguales y luego planes
mientras tanto en rusia empezó este
lunes una semana de vacaciones forzadas
y pagadas para la mayoría de rusos una
política federal con el objetivo de
revertir la tendencia creciente de
nuevos contagios y de alentar la
vacunación entre una población escéptica
hasta los 13 años no creo que ayude no
creo que estas medidas ayuden para nada
es una semana de no trabajo pero la
gente trabaja así es
creo que sí ayudará veo que la gente no
tiene muchas ganas de vacunarse espero
que ahora vayan a recibir el fármaco
al tiempo que el mundo avanza a
distintas velocidades hacia la
recuperación los líderes de las 20
potencias mundiales acordaron en italia
de nuevo una acción multilateral para
ayudar a los países pobres a dejar atrás
la crisis sanitaria y desde este lunes
en la cob 26 se espera el debate sobre
como la prevención de nuevas pandemias
depende en gran medida de la acción
climática
vamos a conversar ahora con el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez médico infectólogo
asesor científico de france 24 cara
habitual aquí en el programa en com y 19
la semana en américa doctor bienvenido a
la consulta como siempre un gusto
conversar con usted hablemos de varios
anuncios que tuvieron desarrollo a lo
largo de esta semana por ejemplo en eeuu
fue autorizada la vacuna de facer en
dosis pediátricas para mayores de 5 años
también en colombia fue avalada la
vacuna de sinovac para los mayores de 3
años como preparar a los menores para
poder recibir esta inoculación esta
primera dosis que cuidados deben de
tener los padres ante las reacciones que
puedan tener los menores al recibir
estas vacunas
sin santiago una cosa muy importante es
la vacunación en los niños ha mostrado
un principio es segura es decir que esta
vacunación no produce efectos deletéreos
en la salud de los niños lo que ha
demostrado los estudios recordemos que
la vacunación está adelante en menores
en países como chile como ecuador y
recientemente colombia es que las
vacunas son seguras y efectivas y
previenen la infección en este grupo de
edad pueden producirse las reacciones
naturales la fiebre el malestar como
sucede en los adultos pero generalmente
son muy bien generados no hay efectos
adversos severos como los choc
anafilácticos los casos que se
escribieron en las vacunas en adultos y
eso nos hace confiar que esta vacunación
sea masiva en esta población y los
necesitamos para controlar la pandemia
doctor pérez la actual tasa de
transmisión del coronavirus en el
continente europeo es considerada por la
oms como muy preocupante ya lo hemos
conversado en otros programas pero qué
es lo que está pasando en europa que
merece que prestemos atención aquí en
américa para prevenir también un
incremento esta incidencia de casos tal
parece que no ha sido fácil de frenar
allí en el continente europeo ya lo
hemos dicho acá es un espejo como
debemos prevenir evitar que estemos en
dos meses en el mismo escenario
en esta semana el gobierno alemán hizo
un llamado que estaban ante una cuarta
ola pero que les preocupaba que eran los
no vacunados y una de las cosas que
preocupa es que en euro ahora y en
europa y una reticencia a la vacunación
en la población adulta y también en la
población de menores y allá el problema
no es la suficiencia de las vacunas sino
la reticencia a vacunarse y eso ha
explicado este incremento en el número
de casos mientras haya población
susceptible es decir no vacunada va a
incrementarse la posibilidad de nuevas
variantes de nuevos casos y de asistir a
los ambientes hospitalarios y la
mortalidad lo que hemos visto en europa
y en otros sitios es la fe y lo veíamos
en rusia en el especial que nos estaba
mostrando ahora es que la gente no se
quiere vacunar y esas personas son las
que han enfermado nosotros en américa
latina es hacer vacunación masiva como
parte de la seguridad para que no haya
una cuarta ola tan impactante doctores
que lo hemos dicho acá varias veces a lo
largo de todo este año y en este
programa la vacunación es clave para
poder mitigar el impacto de esta
pandemia paso preguntarle por otro tema
destacado de la semana una píldora un
medicamento el mono pira bird que se
utiliza para combatir el kobe 19 porque
éste funciona exactamente en el
organismo como un atacante de una enzima
que evita que el virus pueda seguir
reproduciéndose en el organismo esto
complementa la vacuna es mejor que la
vacuna es para otra instancia que
suplementa a una vacunación con un
esquema completo que se dice en el mundo
médico sobre este medicamento
este es un medicamento supremamente
interesante y abre las puertas para una
gran cantidad de medicamentos que vienen
como antivirales efectivos que es lo que
hace es que produce un nucleótido un
ladrillo que se necesita para hacer la
replicación y es el ladrillo se hace
falsamente y eso impide la replicación
viral estos medicamentos son complemento
a la vacuna recordemos que para
controlar la pandemia tenemos que hacer
algo preventivo como la vacuna y algo
efectivo que son estos medicamentos
algunas personas que sufren infección
duran vacuna van a ser tratados con
estos medicamentos y no van a llegar al
hospital eso hace que estas píldoras
anticonceptivas
para controlar la pandemia nos hacía
falta un tratamiento efectivo ya tenemos
varios tratamientos efectivos en
desarrollo estamos pendientes de los
estudios de aprobación para poderlo
implementar en toda la región que la cne
requerimos con urgencia doctor le
transmite una de las preguntas que
recibimos a través de las redes sociales
y esta es de una persona que está por
recibir la segunda dosis de vacunación y
nos pregunta si ahora es mejor que
reciba la segunda dosis de la misma
vacuna que recibió en la primera o si
puede combinar y todo esto para poder
tener un mejor efecto en su organismo
para atacar o defenderse del cob y 19 se
puede combinar en una segunda dosis no
en la tercera de refuerzo que es un tema
que ya hemos analizado acá
si se pueden reforzar la segunda dosis
puede ser con otra casa farmacéutica
otro mecanismo de acción otra plataforma
es lo que se llama pauta heteróloga es
muy similar cuando se hace homóloga o
heteróloga lo que se ha demostrado es
que sea una o sea la otra son seguros
son efectivos hay varios estudios que
muestran que la combinación de las
vacunas puede ser incluso un poco mejor
pero la recomendación es la segunda
entonces puede ser con la misma inicial
o si hay otra plataforma disponible
colocarse la otra plataforma que no
tiene ningún problema médico y la
seguridad y efectividad igual o similar
a la pauta homóloga esta pauta pero lo
va a sufrir la insuficiencia de
biológicos que hemos tenido en la región
se ha mostrado como una estrategia
segura y seguramente el futuro de la
vacunación va a ser con estas pautas de
terol o gas como se hacen los refuerzos
y se puede hacer sin ningún problema se
puede vacunar con la segunda dosis con
otra plataforma
bueno más claro imposible doctor muchas
gracias por este mensaje ya lo saben a
vacunarse
no importa con qué tipo de vacuna de
leche es que ustedes puedan recibir la
inmunización para poder hacer frente al
cob el 19 muchas gracias doctor por
estar con nosotros aquí en el programa
buen fin de semana vamos a cambiar de
tema hay alerta por el incremento de
casos en diferentes países de europa y
de asia central ya lo veníamos
comentando la falta de equidad en la
distribución de las vacunas dificultan
los esfuerzos para detener el avance de
los contagios américa latina también
comienza a registrar incremento de casos
en algunos países como chile y paraguay
nuevamente epicentro de la pandemia
europa y asia central sufren un aumento
de contagios por kobe 19 a pesar de cada
una haber inoculado con el esquema
completo a casi el 40 por ciento de su
población total de corn space of
transmisión o el ritmo actual de
transmisión en los 53 países de la
región de europa es motivo de gran
preocupación los casos de komi 19 se
acercan cada vez más a niveles récord
con la variante delta más transmisible
que continúa dominando la transmisión en
europa y asia tendrán tu dominates
transmisión cross europa en center stage
jon según la agencia europea de
medicamentos actualmente son
responsables del 59 por ciento de todos
los casos a nivel mundial y del 48 por
ciento de las muertes informadas y si la
región sigue su trayectoria actual para
febrero del próximo año podrían morir
medio millón de personas más esto a
pesar de que en europa y asia central se
han administrado mil millones de dosis
según la onu sin embargo la cobertura es
bastante dispar mientras que varios
países como españa y portugal
han inmunizado a más del 60 por ciento
de su población con el esquema completo
en otros como ucrania la tasa sigue
siendo inferior al 20%
porque se deberían enviar más vacunas a
países que ya han vacunado a más de 40
por ciento de su población y ccoo hasta
que kóvacs tenga las vacunas que
necesita para ayudar a otros países a
llegar allí también es no se deberían
administrar más refuerzos excepto a
personas inmunodeprimidas
usted excepto tourism in compromise
people lo mismo sucede en américa latina
en países como chile donde el 80% de la
población está totalmente vacunada los
contagios van en un preocupante aumento
ante la llegada de las distintas
variantes del coronavirus lo mismo ha
empezado a suceder en república
dominicana y barbados la relajación de
medidas en varios países de américa y el
objetivo de fin de año podrían
acercarlos aún más a la situación que
vive el continente europeo
bueno y es que miren las cifras si
comparamos los continentes europa
contabilizó más de 293 mil 300 casos
diarios en promedio a lo largo de esta
semana una cifra muy superior si la
comparamos con norteamérica en donde el
promedio está por encima de 91 mil casos
de contagio confirmados américa del sur
tiene un promedio diario de más de
22.300 casos de contagio
y esta semana el gobierno de colombia
expedirá un expidió un decreto en el que
le exige a la población un carné de
vacunación contra kobe 19 la medida
abarca todo el territorio nacional y
también será obligatorio para ingresar a
lugares públicos y también privados este
país también está avanzando en la
vacunación de menores de edad
comprendidas en edades entre los 3 y los
11 años
colombia endurece las medidas para
controlar el hobbit 19 el presidente
iván duque confirmó desde parís que una
prueba de vacunación contra el
coronavirus será obligatoria para los
mayores de edad la decisión aplica para
mayores de 18 años desde el mes de
diciembre se exigirá el esquema completo
de vacunación la medida aplicará para
eventos presenciales de carácter público
o privado que impliquen asistencia
masiva como en bares cines discotecas
casinos iglesias museos entre otros la
decisión busca establecer que sectores
de la población ya han sido inoculados
ya que muchos ciudadanos salieron de
colombia a vacunarse en el extranjero
entretanto desde el 31 de octubre niños
y niñas entre los 3 y los 11 años
empezaron a ser vacunados con el
biológico del laboratorio chino sinovac
esta vacunación tiene varios objetivos
el primero proteger la vida de nuestros
niños de 3 a 11 años que si bien tienen
efectos menores tienen igualmente
riesgos pero también proteger a la
población de la edad los niños los
jóvenes los adultos todos podemos hacer
cuadros síntomas sintomáticos y ser
transmisores la vacuna minimiza es el
riesgo del contagio según el ministerio
de salud colombiano tan solo el fin de
semana más de 22 mil niños en el país
fueron vacunados contra el sars cop 2 lo
que impulsará su regreso a las aulas
colombia superó el martes la barrera de
los 5 millones de contagiados y registra
más de 127 mil muertes y aunque en los
meses de junio y julio registró tasas
bajas de contagios diarios que hicieron
pensar en el fin de la pandemia el
instituto nacional de salud advirtió que
no es el momento de bajar la guardia ya
que las nuevas variantes del virus
siguen circulando
veamos ahora cómo está avanzando la
vacunación en el continente americano
les presento a continuación el
porcentaje de la población con esquema
de vacunación completo en algunos países
del continente comienzo dándoles una
cifra global el 39 33 por ciento de la
población del mundo ya tiene el esquema
completo de vacunación en nuestra región
guatemala cierra esta semana con el
18,15 por ciento de la población con
esquema completo ecuador allí las cifras
de alcanza el 56 a 41 por ciento
trinidad y tobago en la costa norte de
suramérica el 43 53 por ciento de la
población ya tiene el esquema completo
finalizamos en paraguay en donde
terminan esta semana con el
32,71 por ciento de la población
vacunada
y después de varios meses con sus
fronteras cerradas y con muchas
limitaciones para el ingreso incluso
para los mismos ciudadanos argentina
decidió abrir las fronteras para
permitir el ingreso de los extranjeros
una apuesta que no deja de ser
arriesgada pero que beneficia a la
deteriorada economía argentina vamos a
ver cómo está la situación allí con
natalio con psoe nuestro corresponsal en
la ciudad de buenos aires- natalia como
siempre un gusto tenerlo aquí en el
programa y cuál es el balance que hacen
las autoridades argentinas de esta
apertura de las fronteras no solamente
las autoridades también que dicen los
argentinos de esta medida
a partir del primero de noviembre ya
puede entrar a argentina turismo de
cualquier parte del mundo es una
decisión que tomó el gobierno nacional
por la situación epidemiológica de kobe
19 pero también porque más de un 50 por
ciento de la población tiene al menos
una dosis de vacuna contra esta
enfermedad
el primero de noviembre mismo según la
dirección nacional de migraciones
ingresaron a argentina a algo más de 2
mil 800 turistas hay que recordar que en
marzo de 2020 argentina decide decidió
cerrar sus puertas al turismo como una
forma de prevenir el ingreso y los
contagios mayores de kobe 19 y esto hizo
que la comparativa entre 2020 y 2019 la
cantidad de turistas que ingresaron al
país cayera en un 77 por ciento y
consecuentemente cayera en miles de
millones de dólares la cantidad de
divisas que ingresaron al país por la
fuente del turismo natal yo me imagino
que hay una gran expectativa en torno a
esta apertura de las fronteras muchos
sectores se benefician pero emergencia
sanitaria persiste allí en este país
progresivamente se van normalizando las
frecuencias de los vuelos que llegan del
exterior también de los cruceros que
visitan el país la apertura de las
fronteras terrestres hay mucha
expectativa en el sector por la
necesidad de que ingresen divisas del
exterior tanto para la necesidad de
importaciones que pueda tener el país
como también para los deseos de ahorro
que tienen los argentinos que buscan
habitualmente el ahorro en dólares como
una forma segura para cubrirse frente a
la inflación y frente a las
devaluaciones unas devaluaciones que en
este momento con la moneda con el peso
argentino tan devaluado hace que sea un
destino atractivo para países donde los
ciudadanos tienen monedas fuertes y ahí
es donde hay una cierta expectativa del
sector de lograr atraer un turismo más
grande más importante mayor número de
personas que visiten el país está
también la preocupación por el aumento
de casos en algunas partes de europa que
ese es un turismo que se desea
especialmente en argentina porque
comparando por ejemplo con países de la
región con países vecinos gastan
muchísimo más dinero cuando visitan el
país pero en todo caso el sector turismo
está muy expectante
por las divisas y también por supuesto
por la creación de puestos de trabajo
natalio ya con la economía otra vez en
marcha las fronteras abiertas que
medidas sanitarias mantienen allí en
argentina porque como ya lo decíamos la
emergencia persiste no solamente allí
sino en el mundo entero
lo fundamental lo esencial en este
momento en argentina es la campaña de
vacunación argentina ya está vacunando a
niños a partir de los 3 años y está
dando terceras dosis a personas de más
de 3 años que tengan alguna situación de
inmunosupresión y también a mayores de
50 que hayan recibido la vacuna sino
fandós dosis de vacunas scinopharm por
otro lado rigen algunas pequeñas
restricciones y recomendaciones el uso
de tapabocas por ejemplo en espacios
interiores pero en general se han
relajado muchísimo las restricciones
sobre todo si se compara con lo que fue
el año 2020 esa es la situación el foco
como decía en argentina ahora
esencialmente está puesto en la
vacunación
natalia gracias por este completo
reporte desde la ciudad de buenos aires-
en natalio soy reportando nos desde la
capital argentina nos vamos a chile un
país líder en vacunación en nuestra
región pero también hay preocupación
porque también están aumentando los
casos de contagio allí lo hemos
analizado ya en programas anteriores
veamos cómo están las cifras solamente
esta semana los casos de contagio en
chile en un 4% eso nos lleva a un total
nacional de 17 millones de casos
confirmados desde el inicio de la
pandemia los fallecidos ya sobrepasan
los 37 mil 800 y los vacunados con
esquema completo llegan al 79 49 por
ciento este país lidera también en la
inoculación de la tercera dosis
y en uruguay han mencionado la
posibilidad de levantar la
obligatoriedad del uso de las
mascarillas pero este país allí también
autorizaron el levantamiento de las
restricciones en las fronteras y pueden
ingresar a este país todos los
visitantes extranjeros que lo deseen
vamos a conocer cómo está la situación
allí para hablar con karina de almas en
la ciudad de montevideo para conocer
detalles karina balance que hacen las
autoridades de esta primera semana del
levantamiento de las fronteras allí en
uruguay
así de santiago euro vio un año y ocho
meses uruguay abrió sus fronteras para
los turistas si bien se había especulado
con un aluvión de turistas
argentinos esto no se dio señalan los
analistas que es en parte debido a que
una tercera dosis de vacuna de refuerzo
para aquellos turistas que ingresaban al
país que ha sido ofrecida por el
gobierno uruguayo aún no está disponible
sin embargo pese a que los ferrys que
cruzan buenos aires montevideo
llegan con la mitad de su capacidad en
el primer día de apertura de fronteras y
llegaron a uruguay unas 3.000 personas
en su mayoría por vía aérea la
conectividad internacional a nivel aérea
ha resurgido se han vuelto a abrir
líneas que antes estaban suspendidas y
los vuelos en su mayoría llegan
completos en otro tema también las
líneas que conectan buenos aires con el
exclusivo balneario
de punta el este ya todas los pasajes
para los meses de noviembre y diciembre
están vendidos esto sin embargo es un
número pequeño de turistas y un nivel
económico alto bueno sin duda alguna
karina esto es una forma del gobierno
uruguayo de prepararse precisamente para
la temporada de verano el gobierno
quiere ver esas playas uruguayas llenas
de turistas tanto brasileños como
argentinos y de otros países de
suramérica qué expectativas hay allí no
solamente en el sector turístico sino en
otros sectores de la economía con esta
apertura
bueno en este sentido santiago sucedido
un optimismo con mucha cautela en un
buen año con una excelente temporada de
verano el turismo implica el 8% del
producto bruto interno del país por lo
cual es una industria en la cual tanto
autoridades como operadores están muy
atentos de lo que pase en las próximas
semanas
mayoritariamente los turistas que llegan
a uruguay son argentinos y brasileros en
este momento sobre todo hacia argentina
la diferencia cambiaria hace que uruguay
sea un país caro para venir a vacacionar
pero sin embargo el viceministro de
turismo romances le indicó que si bien
no se espera una temporada maravillosa
comparada con la temporada anterior se
cree que va a ser buena dijo que el
público objetivo es aquel que valora la
situación sanitaria del país le gusta la
costa atlántica uruguaya
un poder adquisitivo medio alto alto el
presidente de la república luis lacalle
pou indicó que si bien esta temporada
la llegada de turistas no debería de
modificar la situación sanitaria si
sería una campaña de reactivación de la
industria turística y desestimó la
importancia que pueda tener
la diferencia cambiaria con argentina
karina pero todo esto es posible porque
hay algunas medidas sanitarias que
todavía se mantienen cuáles son las
restricciones que se mantienen allí en
la república oriental del uruguay
uruguay le exige a los turistas que
ingresen tener la pauta completa de
vacunación para los mayores de edad los
menores de edad pueden ingresar sin
haber sido vacunados y pueden optar por
vacunarse dentro de uruguay también
pueden ingresar las personas que hayan
tenido la enfermedad los últimos 90 días
y pueden mostrarlo por medio de un test
y antígenos a todas las personas que
ingresan al país se le pide un test pcr
negativo de kobe 19 y también una
declaración jurada que se debe realizar
online previo a el ingreso al país desde
el ministerio de turismo señalan que la
prueba de fuego del punto de vista
sanitario va a ser en las próximas
semanas cuando lleguen más de 70 mil
personas para ver las tres finales de
fútbol que van a estar ocurriendo aquí
en el estadio centenario en montevideo
las autoridades señalaron que las
entradas se vendieron en tiempos récord
y se espera que lleguen al menos 70.000
personas al respecto el presidente luis
lacalle pou señaló que una vez más la
ciudadanía apeló a la responsabilidad
social en ese sentido en mantener las
medidas sanitarias y el distanciamiento
y dijo bueno que si ocurren nuevos
brotes se van a tener que volver a tomar
medidas más restrictivas
gracias karina por este reporte karina
de almas desde montevideo con detalles
de esta apuesta del gobierno uruguayo de
cara a la temporada de verano vamos a
cambiar de tema la farmacéutica pfiezer
indicó que son positivos los resultados
preliminares de su píldora contra el
kobe 19 que servirá para reducir hasta
en un 89 por ciento según los ensayos el
riesgo de hospitalización y también la
muerte de los pacientes es la segunda
píldora de este tipo la primera que fue
dada a conocer fue desarrollada por la
farmacéutica merck
una nueva esperanza en la lucha por
controlar la pandemia la farmacéutica
estadounidense pfizer anunció los
resultados sobre la efectividad de una
nueva pastilla antiviral contra el
coronavirus bajo el nombre de pax lobby
nos enorgullece anunciar que según
nuevos datos nuestro candidato a
antiviral oral contra el kobe 19
demostró reducir significativamente el
riesgo de muerte u hospitalización en
adultos de alto riesgo según fischer el
fármaco está diseñado para bloquear una
enzima que el coronavirus necesita para
hacer copias de sí mismo de este modo se
evita que invada al infectado con esta
tecnología se conseguiría una reducción
del 89% en la tasa de hospitalización y
muertes de pacientes infectados por kobe
la altísima eficacia nos sorprende
incluso a nosotros supera las
expectativas más visionarias que
teníamos al respecto
ahora nos lanzaremos de inmediato a ver
qué más podemos hacer en la fabricación
de suministro en el estudio participaron
mil 219 personas de ellos 775 tomaron la
píldora la farmacéutica estima que
podría producir 180.000 paquetes del
fármaco para finales de este año la
cifra ascendería a 50 millones en 2022
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden se pronunció sobre la noticia
ya hemos asegurado millones de dosis y
la terapia sería una herramienta más
para proteger a la gente de los peores
resultados del cob y ambos anuncios
llegan un día después de que reino
unido- aprobara el uso de una píldora
similar desarrollada por la farmacéutica
merck sin embargo este fármaco destinado
principalmente a personas con factores
de riesgo presenta solamente una
efectividad del 50 por ciento y
previamente les presentamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana en
nuestro continente brevemente les cuento
que costa rica es recibió 111 mil dosis
adicionales de la vacuna desarrollada
por facer variante para reforzar su plan
de vacunación que está en desarrollo
también por espacio de 24 horas paraguay
no registró fallecidos por kobe 19 una
noticia que es alentadora pero preocupa
el aumento de los casos de contagio tal
como también están sucediendo en otros
países de la región como chile por
ejemplo y previamente les cuento que
cuba envió a nicaragua un nuevo lote de
la vacuna soberana 2 desarrollada en
esta isla del caribe es un lote
adicional a 1 que ya habían enviado
anteriormente de 15 millones de dosis
que ya está siendo usado para inocular a
los ciudadanos nicaragüenses
y también fue noticia esta semana en
eeuu la autorización dada para la vacuna
de la farmacéutica pfiezer contra el
kobe y 19 para que sea suministrada en
dos dosis pediátricas a los menores de
edad a partir de ahora todos aquellos
mayores de cinco años ya pueden
inocularse
entre aplausos de sus amigos karim de 6
años recibe su primera dosis de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 como el 28
millones de estadounidenses de entre 5 y
11 años ya son elegibles para recibir el
fármaco the fighter
realmente no hace daño pero háganlo por
el bien de eeuu porque esto es ayudar a
eeuu y al mundo y que la vida sea mejor
para todas y cada una de las personas
del planeta
las autoridades aprobaron el fármaco
para los pequeños el martes alegando que
el riesgo de efectos secundarios graves
es menor en los niños además el virus
tiene fuertes impactos en la salud
mental de la población infantil y agravó
las desigualdades en el acceso a la
educación la vacuna también se aplica en
dos dosis con tres semanas de diferencia
entre cada una pero la cantidad aplicada
es sólo una tercera parte de la usada
para adolescentes y niños un estudio
reciente de los centros de control y
prevención de enfermedades señala que de
entre mil padres el 57% declaro que
vacunar a sus hijos
[Música]
creo completamente en la vacuna en la
ciencia he leído artículos donde
explican que los beneficios superan los
posibles efectos secundarios
sin embargo algunos padres discrepan la
principal preocupación es el riesgo de
inflamación del corazón detectado en
adolescentes y jóvenes después de
vacunarse con pzifer o modernas
no creo que ningún padre de va a poner
esto en el cuerpo de sus hijos en eeuu
más de 8.300 personas de entre 5 y 11
años han sido hospitalizadas por kobe 19
de entre las cuales un tercio precisó
cuidados intensivos según los datos del
gobierno
ahora demos un vistazo a otras noticias
relacionadas con el hobby 19 destacadas
en redes comenzamos con esta publicación
del diario 'los ángeles times' 12
estados demandan al gobierno de bailén
por exigir vacunas los fiscales de 12
estados solicitaron a un juez federal
que bloqueen esta medida del presidente
parte en que obliga a los empleados y
también a contratistas federales a
vacunarse porque supone una
extralimitación federal y veamos esta
publicación de france 24 punto com el
reino unido es el primer país en el
mundo en aprobar una actividad contra el
jove 19 se trata del número pi david que
ya lo mencionamos en este programa el
medicamento que será usado en el reino
unido para tratar a personas que ya
están contagiadas con kobe 19 y que
tienen al menos un factor de riesgo para
desarrollar una enfermedad grave este
medicamento puede ser tomado en pastilla
o también puede ser inyectado
es todo por el momento aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa le recordamos que
pueden ver estas y otras ediciones del
programa en france24 punto com también
en las redes sociales sigan cuidándose
del hobby 19 nosotros nos vemos la
próxima semana hasta entonces
[Música]